oh I doing that now she can probably
tell right good evening everybody my
name's Andy Chrome firewall which and
tonight's plan a meeting and the purpose
of the meeting is to start the planning
man merits the applications before us
before we start me didn't come inshore
everybody's phone is either on silent or
switched off cuz there's nothing more
annoying than smooth in full flow and
then the tuner the Great Escape suddenly
goes around the room and everybody else
starts whistling I'd get accused of
whistling the Great Escape of guys name
and again can we just not interrupt the
speakers many people are registered to
speak all their to speak tonight it
might be very tempting to interrupt but
unfortunately can I ask you to bear with
us interrupt and again before we start
the meeting I'll just stand a little
tribute to catch the bonds he was on
planning committee for with me for many
years something next to catch the
fielding it was almost like a double act
between counts the filming accounts the
bonds and and occasionally catch the
bonds Easter brings Jack Russell and
sometimes and you know it was alleged
that the Jack Russell spoke more sense
in some of the cancers but I couldn't
obviously comment on that but yeah so be
it sir first meeting when item sir I
will miss him certainly so thank you
right we'll move on to the first item of
the agenda which is apologies for
absence of it oh we could do yeah you
could right I was just been told I've
been going on about the Great Escape too
much but to introduce the top table
Olivia Queen Democratic services
make sure - legal services my name is
Dave Jeffrey I'm the planning manager
for tonight's meeting my role is to
provide impartial advice to clarify any
planning issues that arise and to assist
members decision taking in doing so I'm
bound by the Royal Town Planning
Institute's code of Professional Conduct
and planning committee members are not
bound by advice from officers or by
their recommendations Aaron whether
stone planner
Helen Abbas planning officer right - the
first item of the agenda which is
apologies for absence apologies from
councillor JUnit who counselor Eden is
suffering for Thank You councillor do
and this could be a reciprocal
arrangement I'll brief right disclosures
of interest and he describes us capsule
fairing yeah
item five twelve to eleven yourself or
priors that's in my ward so obviously
office it out for that but I'm also
registered to speak I would support to
the parish council thank you very much
cats the Kathy just a paraffin order bar
guidance I will be using my public media
to be looking at the applications and
slightly information not for any private
use during the meeting I'm happy yeah
that's Karen gasps Katelyn right two
minutes are we happy casket oh thank you
I'm happy that I signed the minutes of
the meeting on 11th of December is a
true record I can do I was like oh yeah
see that going swimmingly just on a wood
light no to bring application number six
which is 19 plus 0 2 3 2 7 /
you are 48 Hartford Road Ulster that
would like to bring that forward on the
agenda and if you're happy for me to do
that oh there's a good reason for that
right so move on to that one application
it's not zero to three to seven
structure if you want all 48 Alfred
order this has only came to council
committee because of objection from the
parish council and the objection is now
been resumed removed so on supposing
that we starts 10 caps on approach
council my apologies and I'm proposing
that we delegate this decision to
officers I'm just looking for somebody
to conduct cancer fielding all those in
favor
Thank You committee was asked to do the
grant application going to slash 33 to
7/2 fel two offices in that decision
thank you to the next item agenda which
is application number 19 / 0 1 5 1 0 fu
Outlander would inform the garden of
lower farmhouse excellent Stockton
Thank You chairman the applications
fight lies to the southwest of Stockton
village Pat identified by the black dot
on this plan just here the site forms a
part of the plan between Beck's Lane and
Laurel Drive and falls within the draft
built-up area boundary the Stockton
which is identified as a category 2
local service village within the
council's adopted core strategy this
slide identifies the application site
outlined in red just here beside
comprises of a parcel of land with
vehicle access to the south of the site
from Beck's Lane
approximately here the access to the
site is also shared by public
right-of-way SM - 9 which you can see
with the green dashed line
carrying onto the playing field to the
southwest of the site for planning
permission is sought for the erection of
three dwellings with associated works
including creation of a shared driveway
and parking area neighboring dwellings
lie along Laurel Drive which is here
facing onto the site and pecks lane 37
lower Drive lies here and Laurel House
lies here but it's garden adjoining the
site the same 237 level drive as the
gardener joins the application site this
slide shows an aerial image of the area
it's got the application site
approximately outlined with a red line
and you can see the neighboring property
is on Laurel Drive Laurel house here
with its garden property is on flex lane
and the access going down to the playing
fields which is just over here this
slide shows the proposed site plan for
the development proposal comprised of
one pair of semi-detached dwellings and
one detached property we've got the pair
of semi detached properties here and the
detached property here all three
dwellings are proposed to have three
bedrooms with two stories of
accommodation and rooms in the roof
served by roof flights existing access
from the south of the site is proposed
to be improved and would deserve a
shared parking area of parking for six
vehicles purchased in here we've seen
that six parking spaces here the
dwellings would have gardens to the rear
that would front onto Beck's lanes
you've got rear gardens here and there
we shared open space onto Laurel Drive
and a pedestrian access point just here
in this approximate location existing
landscaping along Beck's Lane here to
propose to be retained as all mature
trees for north of the site to the top
of the slide shows a section with Beck's
Lane here on the right-hand side going
up to Laurel Drive there is a change in
ground level from Beck's Lane with
properties on Laurel Drive at a higher
level and this is just showing where the
proposed dwellings would be in relation
to the boundaries of the site this slide
shows the proposed elevations the
dwellings are simple in design with
pitch roofs a gable feature and canopies
the development proposed to be finished
and rendered brick and tile so canopy
features here gable feature
render elements brick elements for tile
and on the rear brick you can see the
roof light windows which serve the rooms
in the roof space this photograph shows
an image of the entrance to the site
from Beck's Lane just on the left-hand
side where the footpath follows the
route in a southwesterly direction
lead 15 vegetation which encloses the
site is shown to the right of the image
this photograph was taken looking into
the site from Beck's Lane I think see
the existing access point to the left of
the image is 37 Laurel Drive with its
garden to the rear here and other
property is on Laurel Drive which face
towards the site this photograph is
taken from within the site looking
towards Laurel Drive and see number 37
Laurel Drive just here next photograph
is just panning across the site with the
final photograph here looking towards
Laurel house you can see in the
background of the image with the mature
trees to the north of the site shown in
the center of the image this photograph
was taken looking across the garden of
Laurel house and seal old ride to the
north the trees in the previous
photograph just over here
and the rear elevation of Laurel house
to the right of the image moving along
the X Lane got the application site on
the left hand side with the existing
vegetation and properties on Beck's Lane
which faced towards the site this
photograph was taken from Laurel Drive
you can see the open space here amenity
land
number 37 Laurel Drive here and the
extent of the application site is
approximately here this final slide
shows a photograph of Laurel Drive
you've got 37 Laurel Drive just here on
the left of the image just panning
around to get a better feel for the
street scene
the number of updates which have been
circulated on the update sheet the
development is considered to represent a
small-scale development within the
physical confines of Stockton which is
identified as a category two local
service village within the core strategy
when considering all the elements within
the planning balance and subject
conditions and notes it is recommended
that plan information be granted for the
development thank you Karlsson from
Stockton Thank You mr. chairman Howard
Collison chairman of Stockton Parish
Council objects to this application on
the following grounds stop to this class
as a cutter group
Caterpie to local service village than
the core strategy states that there
should be approximately 700 programs
across the category two villages would
no more than 12% in an individual
settlement ie
84 since the plan period commenced in
2011 Stockton is at 110 permissions
granted so exceeds the limit by 30% with
12 years left in the plan period the
Parish Council wants to see any future
developments spread over the whole plant
period and we'd only support small-scale
development during the Rainforest period
where they meet the needs of existing
local families and also measurable
benefit to the community is demonstrated
the applicant has not carried out an
assessment of the need for properties of
this nature they claim these properties
are aligned to affordable homes and will
be available to first-time buyers Taylor
Wimpey
has recently released 26 new homes in
the village in the last 12 months of the
18 shared ownership properties only
seven went to families with an immediate
Stockton connection the other eleven
twenty families from the wider area this
would indicate that without a new
housing needs assessment there is no
local need for properties of this time
the Taylor Wimpey homes were shared
equity and it is likely that they would
be less expensive than these houses that
would be at full market value the
applicants purpose of aiming the houses
that local first-time buyers does not
seem to fit in
with the current situation in Stockton
the proposed layout is based on a high
density of housing on such a small
footprint and so represents an over
development of the site and the design
of the houses has no relationship with
homes around it the access onto the site
comes out onto Beck's Lane at the same
location has a public footpath which is
heavily used as it leads to the village
playing field and is often used by
unaccompanied children this represents
an unacceptable safety risk as there is
quite limited parking space within the
development it is likely that any
visitor parking would be on the narrow
Beck's Lane and the entrance to the
playing field access path the parish
council would have no objection to a
less intensive development on this site
that was in keeping with a local stream
scene and method identified local
housing need and has a different access
30 seconds in conclusion I refer to
policy AS 10 of the core strategy this
states that in local villages all other
types of development unless covered by a
specific policy in the core strategy
will need to be fully justified however
if the committee of minded to approve
this application I would ask that in the
design of the access onto the
development the road design makes proper
provision for access of both pedestrians
and maintenance vehicles to the path
leading to the plain theology thank you
thank you
the Colson right any questions coach the
fielding
there were three or four bungalows that
were built on the Taylor Wimpey
developments that were released about a
year ago and there's one bungalow just
about to go on the market elsewhere in
the village a single building but they
not aimed at older people and they just
generally them for sale market property
so just go just make sure we stick to
the application that's in front of us I
assume you were trying to get as counsel
counsel mentioned local need in this
part of the objection and you are
assuming you were trying to get to what
the local need was full of are cancels
out what you're trying to get today
rather than actually mention embalm
that's right thank you can successfully
indicate when did you long as I may have
missed it but when she lost our housing
needs survey 2011 I think how many has
he had built since 2011 well most of
those hundred and ten houses and what
was the need in 2011 I think at that
time it was about 25 we identified okay
Castle knows yeah did you have any
consultation from the developer with
parish council at all on this and we
initially had some consultation about
three years ago when oddly enough it was
a single bungalow but those never came
forward to a planning application this
was just discussions with the parish
council but we've had no further
consultations nothing on this new
negative there like anything right
thank you : yeah thank you go
I'm Alex Adam five minutes cancel Adam
just to make sure so I'll give you a
warning shot with a metaphorical warning
shot
yes Thank You chair Thank You committee
the number of houses built in the
village in recent years has exceeded the
recommended limits set by the council's
own core strategy house the local
service village caps Cree to Stockton
should attract no more than eighty four
houses within the period however the
limit has already been exceeded
primarily by the building of two large
estates increasing the number of houses
in the village five hundred and ten over
30% in excess of the recommended amount
I know that the officers report makes
reference to this but fails to fully
justify our more development of any
scale will not further in perhaps when
considering recent development in the
village and local area as it stands I
support small development small infill
developments as a more sensitive
approach to delivering housing however
the needs to be a limit one main reason
for having this strategy is to avoid
concentration of building over time and
to allow for local infrastructure to be
developed as well meeting the increased
amount housing has increased in this and
neighbouring wards significantly and yet
the local amenities have not similarly
sill payments have not had time to take
effect improve the infrastructure
required in terms of maintaining
allowance of life for the district to
meet these housing needs into the future
and protect local areas from over
development building on this site now
would mean that meeting this need would
rely on further development outside the
built-up area of boundary and would
therefore likely be a larger scale and a
greater impact on the area demanding
more of you from the infrastructure and
services that as mentioned are already
at capacity
further development at this time would
not only contradict policy
one six but would undermine the strategy
which protects the district from
overdevelopment setting a poor poor
precedent for future applications
therefore there should be a significant
material fact when considering this
application now I don't find the housing
need within the community is also
critical when considering applications
as identified in policy CS 1 9 which
notes all new homes will contribute to
the creation of balanced and sustainable
communities by meeting identified local
and district housing needs in terms of
make size tenure and type K 2 the full
range of different households Stockton
parish plan 2006 includes the comment
small bungalows to think single people
living in large houses there are recent
anecdotal reports of local residents
moving away from the village due to lack
of bungalows despite the recent increase
in housing where sites such as this
would be ideal for such smaller housing
and would limit the impact on neighbors
whose garden will be significantly
overshadowed they need has clearly not
been identified and the proposed
proposal for the site has tried to
include as many bedrooms and houses as
possible given that the majority of the
houses built recently are similar to
those proposed here the application is
clearly not sought to deliver omits to
comply with the strategy and this
concern is therefore relevant when
considering the application in front of
you the density of housing on this site
has also raised numerous concerns around
adequate parking spaces and the road
parking access for emergency vehicles
the impact on local school schools both
in the village and in Salem is the
nearest town we are at or near capacity
the impact on local amenities and
infrastructure and critically the safety
around there only main entrance to the
village playing field which is directly
adjacent to the proposed site entrance
being on a narrow corner with narrow
footpaths I do consider these to be
valid material concerns in terms of
local infrastructure no comments have
been received from 7/10 watter east as
the console t for the impact the
application will have a water and
drainage the site is within a flood zone
and without an important aspect of the
application being commented upon by the
appropriate professional body I cannot
see that the potential risks that are
raised by the application can be
properly identified as suggested by
their officers report the impact of
water runoff and foul drainage must be
considered politically to ensure that
the problems caused by overdevelopment
and either poorly managed or simply
passed on with local water courses and
drainage already feeling the burden of
additional in thermal area and increased
fouling Gratz from both recent and
historic developments this risk must be
identified so so it can be mitigated
managed or avoided as appropriate it's
for these reasons the biota community to
refuse this application thank you very
much the new estates on the other side
of the village they were built on former
allotments and field area so this area
of the village hasn't been developed
since oil drive which is the height was
shown more similar to the new
developments across the village than
they are to the houses around them the
houses that are on Beck's Lane much
older to the original bit will
are they larger than these ones or are
they the same sort of sizes there is a
mixed size around I can't say it darling
watch me of the questions and the
statements as well one when we did
points of clarification I will ask about
the consultation with Water Agency but I
do know that on page 13 says the site
lies in flood zone 1 which is the lowest
that was the probability of flooding
again it's board member and I should
again ask the bright councillor as well
has there been any incidents of flooding
that you know in that area I don't know
of any specific flooding in that area
but the point I was trying to make was
that the professional body and statutory
consultation should have consulted on
this and housing yep we'll find it
doesn't happen but obviously I know I've
been there for good well and used to
play football there fair just trying to
get the point over for members so they
you don't know the area so well to get
the question right thank you right we'll
now move on to points of clarification
catch the meals please
Thank You Erin the proposed development
how much higher are they than the house
is that they back onto we haven't got a
photograph that we yes these are the
property on Laurel Drive so it's a
higher level anyway so side slope sir
yeah the recommendation of subject to
conditions including finished floor
levels we've got section drawings
as you can see here so Laurel drive here
and you can see the increase in the land
as its slopes back down to Beck's Lane
it's a couple of meters in terms of the
change in ground level from Beck's Lane
up to Laurel Drive so what they've
looked to do is the Ridge Heights that
are proposed as part of the development
approximately 8.4 for this property here
and Louisville Drive 7.7 but with the
difference in ground level will be
looking to fix that by condition to make
sure we put all of the other ground
changes as well and so that's a sort of
change in in which height and then as
you go down and the Beck's Lane the
property is at a lower level and so in
terms of the approximate increase over
this is about 65 meters from Beck's Lane
here over to Lowell Drive you're looking
at an increase in three point four
meters they're all they're about in
terms of change in ground level across
from here over to here thank you for
that but will they be sorry I missed the
point there will there be higher than
the existing buildings or the same as
yeah thanks counselor the section here
shows it quite in a nice striated form
these are the proposed dwellings in
grading in the middle you can see
they're rich height in comparison to
those on ok and just one other thing you
know it I'm confused about the axis
their road access to this it's it
through the iron gates that I saw so yes
the access will be improved and it's
down here in the corner the site is
South section the site this is a vehicle
of access with parking for six vehicles
and space to turn around and so you
can't get that photograph up for me
thanks
so this is the area and it's proposed to
be the access the vehicle access to the
site and so mr. chairman
and that will cut across the start of
this footpath limit yeah so it will go
this is the access from the highway the
footpath follows along here and the
bicular access would be coming up and
over you can see the gates approximately
here in the image we have consulted with
rights-of-way and watch the Ramblers
they raised no objection subject to a
note and highways and raised no
objection subjective conditions to the
development sorry Laurel there is a
fairly large gap between Laurel house
and the proposed site it's long house of
any character or is it just a fairly new
build seems quite a large house it's not
a listed building
it does have architectural merit and it
is set on a corner plot which is I bring
up this plan here this is Laurel house
also known as the laurels but it's
garden to the rear and access from
Laurel Drive here on the right-hand side
of the image so it's not been affected
by by this development we've considered
the impact of the development on the
character of the area's part of the
officer assessment
thank you we've got a supplementary
planning document that deals with a
different number of things including
visitor parking and there isn't any
visitor parking on that site and I think
that document refers to something like
noir point two spaces per dwelling for a
three-bedroom house which would round up
to one am i right part of the SBD asks
for two parking spaces and perv
three-bedroom unit it does make
reference to unallocated
visitor space
but that's in this case we've considered
the proposal and we're satisfied that
there are two parking spaces per
dwelling and there are spaces as well
for cycle parking as well just a quick
one another action but the first one is
quick answer in that picture of Laurel
half garden there are four quite
significant reductions what are they so
it's just pads nor garden furniture okay
thank you they're moving on I've got two
areas of concern and then an additional
one that came out from the mayor's
comments which I'm going to deal with
first he's talked about flooding is we
know the flood maps tend to be very
generic by area
what sort of sub schemers are we looking
to put in place and here to prevent
water from here running out on the road
because it'll be a considerable change
in grassed area to to built for the
something does lie in flood zone one
which we've got the lowest probability
of lowest risk of flooding we've
recommended a further condition in the
update sheet for foul and surface water
drainage to be submitted and approved
prior to commencement so we're asking
for those details to come in as part of
the development if the plan that are
minded to approve the scheme like a
general point place when the office is
given an answer can you just let them
finish before interrupted thank you
second point counselor Eden earlier on
referred to supplemental planning
documents and we do have Part D which is
buildings and layout and that has two
issues which I think are relevant to
this application one of which is massing
which is referred to on page 2 of
SPD party and the other one is designing
host types which on page five of the SPD
how have the recommendations of that as
teaming SPD being brought in to this
application because it seems to me that
we have a very different style being
introduced into the street scene point
one point to the SPT refers to in some
way replicating the design that's
already there in the street scene and if
you look in Laurel going to get it right
bit now Laurel Drive all the properties
as you're looking north and to left they
have a gap between each individual house
whereas in this application you've got
basically two similar tax analysis and a
third property also tax but slightly
back very very different from the
existing vernacular and what SPD
building layout suggests is is we're not
actually following that SPD so in this
case we've considered the proposal on
its own merit and looked at the platform
of the neighboring properties and the
relationship of the development with
Laurel Drive where it's got its active
street frontage and that's where it has
its greatest relationship so office is
considered because of the design
features and materials have been
incorporated into the scheme and the
heights and the proposed massing and the
separation along the plot and that it
wouldn't have a harmful impact on the
character of the area when we're looking
at cs9 and the guidance in the SPD and
so that's a few that officers have come
to in this case looking at watts and
Laurel Drive and how they've
incorporated features into the new
development
CACO fasting one then finally if we go
back to the original inspectors report
on the call strategy on a paragraph 268
which on page 79 he identifies under CS
16 that the numbers obsess out in that
policy and I quote in a Part B does
given indicates with the quantum of
developments appropriate for each
category of NS fees taking account of
sustainability criteria in a plan that
approach and this is a planet approach
it is appropriate because big is local
communities and developers a certain
degree to secure a certainty now in this
the document the information given both
by the parish and the ward member we've
got an a suggested number for this
settlement of 84 and yet were 110 some
30% above the allocation which the
inspector signed off with the comment
that it gives developers and residents a
degree of certainty there have been a
significant number of developments in
Stockton some of which we know obtain a
win favor for taylor-wood on their calls
were significantly large developments so
this is a village that has taken quite a
hit how can you save 30 percent when the
inspector in his report to us said the
numbers need to give certainty because
30 percent over on is not certainty
I think we would refer to the NPP F
which extols the government's position
which is to significantly boost housing
supply we are mindful that Assoc s 16
sets out numbers for local service
villages as an approximate and the
numbers are an around figure so we're
not in a position where we should
slavish ly adhere to those figures so we
have looked at this proposal and the
impacts which might accrue from the
delivery of three additional dwellings
for as the report sets out on page 14
we've concluded that there is not a
great deal of evidence to suggest that
services in stopped and not accommodate
the needs of three further dwellings and
so on balance we find that that is a
scheme which is capable of being
supported notwithstanding that there is
110 dwellings currently approved or
committed within the village 106 built
yeah I think that that's in the context
of category two villages overall which
haven't met their total
mmm right any other questions I've got a
couple one Erin could you let me know
what the density on the site is please
and what the David Bell tones this one
while you're looking for density so I
can raise the issue about console t27
Trent all the
agency just in terms of density have
done a quick couple of calculations just
to give an idea the site's approximately
1200 square meters this area here all of
the application site which includes the
shared parking area and the three
dwellings the approximate area for each
of the plots one two and three is about
200 square meters per dwelling and that
includes just to give you an idea of
what we calculated this front section
and the way garden not including this
area to the front which is shared open
space or the parking area over here
looking at Laurel Drive they're very
uniform in terms of the size of the
dwellings on the plots they're
approximately 8 by 8 in terms of depth
and width and the approximate plot sizes
for these properties upon Laurel Drive
varies but it's between just having a
quick look I'm approximately 291 square
meters that was 40 in Laurel Drive which
is across the way up to three hundred
thirty four point eight square meters
which was 16 Laurel Drive just taking a
quick calculation based on the rear and
front garden up to the highway and where
the dwelling is set on the site and
obviously Laurel house is too in a
larger plot and that's fifteen hundred
and five square meters approximately for
the garden in the house and down on
BET's Lane here the properties along
here I've got larger plots mainly
because of the rear gardens which are
much longer to the rear so to give you
an idea the cottage which is this
property here it's 543 square meters
approximately in terms of area which I
can get your mouse just here and I love
eleven apex Lane which is this one it's
about five hundred and thirty square
it's quite fairy but it's quite uniform
upon Laurel Drive and what we're looking
at is the open space in the overall size
you're looking at about 400 square
metres per dwelling when you're thinking
about the overall development of the
site we did consult seven Trent as part
of this development we have received no
response to date that we have
recommended a condition to ensure that
any foul and surface water drainage is
submitted to an approved and that gives
options for different foul drainage and
surface water drainage options as part
of that condition that's on the update
sheet that was circulated this evening
thinking in addition to that is
pertinent to add that the guidance in
respect of flood risk is set out by the
NPP F and he advises planners to prefer
locations which are not inclined towards
flooding so this site being in flood
zone one would be a preferred location
for development in that respect in
comparison to other flood zones the
Environment Agency publishes standing
guidance in respective sites such as
this and they wouldn't comment on an
individual application such as this in a
similar way to lead local flood
authority of the County Council deal
particularly with major applications and
so they wouldn't provide comment on the
flood risk of an application such as
this right
for anyone's cancer the carlson I've got
one question that I should have asked
you before and can you come back to the
table so I can ask this question and I
think you've touched on it but again I
just want clarification that the parish
council wouldn't be opposed to
development on this site but for a
lesson number I'm a different type ie
bungalows was that you said or did I
misunderstand yes yeah we're quite happy
to see the site developed
I mean it's become uncared-for for the
past ten years and he's becoming an
eyesore now so we we would like to see
something happening there either one or
two properties that are more in keeping
with the surrounding density of housing
and preferably a different access or
together maybe onto Laurel Drive okay
thank you I thought just needs to
clarify that and not sort of keep
yourself up - first of all you're here
but it's only just come to me so thanks
very much okay now it's only point more
points of clarification with emphasis no
debate now he wants to start catch the
mouse thanks for chairman yeah anything
was concerning was his access which cuts
across the front of this the start of
this access to the footpath where
children are going to the to a play area
most of the perfect council say more
little more or less the same thing also
a little bit concern about the height
and the other overbearing and then
that's that's settled for me but I know
there's been no objection from the
highways about this access but I have to
say
I'm concerned about mr. chairman so I'll
reserve judgment for the moment thank
you okay
ask us if we can start off with comments
about the NPP F enhancing numbers the
new verse of the NPN yes is much less
bullish in terms of development the
original thing was there's a golden
thread supporting if you remember we saw
that in every single planning
application that came in front of us or
I was there to sustainable development
the new document does see does quite
clearly say that a proved developed plan
should accord with an up to then up - oh
sorry development proposals should have
called an observer development plan
which is our core strategy and part of
our core strategy is the SPD is which
two of us have referred to tonight so
yes the MPP F is in supporters of
sustainable development but I don't
believe the design of these buildings I
know that's a matter of opinion and
officers have an opinion which have
expressed that we are invited to comment
on this because to elected members and
both expressed concern with with also
contrary offs reviewed the officers Part
D of the SPD it's 25 pages I didn't
print all of them off but it is pretty
clear about the need for buildings to
fit in with what is already there and
the design of these buildings being
three-story - and everything else is -
being in some form Terrace tall or
summit attached when there were no other
semi detached properties in that
immediate area both seem to me to
completely conflict with our own adopted
SPD
if they fitted in I wouldn't necessarily
have a any further problem and I agree
with the parish council and that that
this does look like a scruffy to the
ground that eight is a bit of garden
that's been left and something needs to
happen to it but just because something
needs to happen to it doesn't mean that
we need a permanent thing which is going
to be looked at in the future they're
sticking out like a sore thumb and if we
look at the sliders still in front of us
yes the heights relating to the property
on the left is lower but if you look at
the property on the other side of is it
BOTS leaning on bricks line next day I'm
sorry then you've got a very very
significant different line and if you
draw a line from the ridge of both those
two properties you go through I suspect
the roof of this proposal so I just
think the design is awful and one of the
things that we are regularly criticised
about in the public arena is appalling
design now the other houses immediately
talk to it or not things of great beauty
they wouldn't win any architectural
competitions but they are consistent and
if you look through the other properties
in the area there is a consistency that
is missing from this property so it
sticks out to me like a sore thumb we
then go to the numbers game and we have
heard repeatedly that we've got the
number of 14,600 or 2,000 for the NS
fees is an approximate number and it is
not a maximum and it isn't a quota but
that's why I went I remember this from
some years ago another application Peter
drew who carried out the work on our
core strategy and he spent three years
on it
does specifically say the part they he
gives an indication of the quantum of
development now if you get a quantum
development and you're one or two out or
one or two percent out
or 6% then I would say that is within a
regional model of regional margin of
error but when once thought starts
talking about 31% out that's me is
getting to the stage of being
unreasonable and is not giving residents
of Stockton or in fact any other
settlement any assurance that the core
strategy we put together is giving them
any in the worth inspector certainty and
I'm going to use this argument again
later this evening because I think it is
absolutely critical if this was
something that fitted in I probably
really wouldn't worry about it too much
but there are two issues the design is
not in my opinion which is different to
the officers opinion but the design does
not seem to tally with anything in our
own SPD tied in with the numbers game I
think that this is a number of things
going wrong with it and I complete the
small Council Miller to comment about
the impact on the footpath all and
that's of a more minor issue but I think
it's just yet another tag on this one
that says the design is wrong we're out
of the pouch canceled there'd be happy
with development on this side but
something that is more appropriate and I
absolutely agree with the parents
absolution yep just one complication
many accesses do cross public footpaths
or even run on them that's pretty wide
the right of way it comes you have not
objected to it men council family I echo
is very much councilor careful thoughts
about it being of poor design I realize
that's not a material planning concern
but part of this debate goes back to my
earlier question around parking three
bedrooms two parking spaces each
absolutely tick the box but it's
unrealistic to think that
those will never have let's say children
or visitors ever and as we've already
talked about that access there's a
problem there that visitors are going to
further crowd that access or make that
visibility supply worse or that kind of
thing and that really again sort of for
me says that it's it's a port design
absolutely 100% I think it's prime for
development but for me that's a problem
sorry I have done all code you Fleming
for two minutes just because I don't
come that often sorry I'm I'm in total
agreement I think it's a terrible design
it's not in keeping with the street
scene on the other side it's cramped
it's pushed in with the to get the car
parking in I don't see why the car
parking
I appreciate the problem with the
footpath and everything else it would
have been better if they garages could
be in front of each of the properties
and therefore more room given to it I
also feel strongly with what the cancer
Adam said about the fact that there are
people moving away and they need to get
more appropriate building and houses in
the area so I am proposing that we
refuse this I totally agreed to my mind
it's overdeveloped
if there was the one less house then the
parking issue would be a lot better and
probably you could make the footpath a
lot safer it's crammed in it doesn't
seem to be any room for it even a dog
kennel so that's me
can Sephora can you give me the reasons
for I would follow what my earnest
Chairman says the the various points
that he raised I would follow on from
those and I think if you can take his
comments with the PPF and other areas
those will be the points that I would
bring forward ya want everything from
Quinn Thank You chair members I've heard
the debate and I recognize the issue
that's been raised in respective housing
numbers and how that in members Minds
appeared to relate to the design on a
number of appeals we've had inspectors
identify housing numbers within our core
strategy has not a strict limit that is
not to say that they gave it no
consideration on a number of other sites
inspectors have considered that where
there is an over supply of housing
against the approximate figures the
benefit to be afforded new housing
should be accorded weight according to
how much that over-provision has been
found so in this case what I would
suggest is perhaps rather than
identifying a reason which sought a
refusal because they are over the
numbers you might wish to consider what
benefits arises from new housing and how
that balances against the harm that
members appear to have identified in
respect of the design of the development
right off of my tip anything they're not
come back to castigate
I've just taken on board what David it
just said and I think where the Parish
Council is coming from I agree is that
what these three houses will take it to
over a third of the number which is
significant here with my Canton Hatton
laughs it catechetical Willis can't
accounting hat on is it six significant
variation the parish council is willing
to allow some development on that land
to Tania per make it more appropriate so
they can see the benefit to the
community of building on that land but
because of the poor design and because
of the numbers they think the
combination of the factors would cause
damage to their community to the street
scene whereas if there was more
consultation have been more consultation
with parish council Bala developer to
come forward with a scheme that was more
appropriate to them that I would have
probably withdrawn their up an objection
and allowed for their development so I
think this is where the harm to the
community has been identified and that's
where the combination of the porters are
not fitting in with the street scene
potential of the development but we've
sort of part that one with the numbers
as well is the combination of and did
not in fitting but the potential local
need I think it's the combination of
several factors that would probably
would make this unacceptable to the
parish and to the warden and there so
that's that's what this I'm come from
art I think I hope further explain that
clearly enough if you do need some more
clarification that's where I'm coming
from but careful when you wanted to come
back in yeah
[Music]
it's clearly that there would be some
benefit the parish council have
identified there might be a benefit for
the right type of housing on this site
but this is they consider and I share
that view and I think some of my
colleagues around here share that view
this is not the right type of houses we
do we cannot disregard our core strategy
numbers our last five year House explai
calculation which came out in July the
LS fees which were allocated some two
thousand and I go back to inspect his
comments about certainty when out two
thousand four hundred so we can't keep
on feeding the dragon by saying there is
always a benefit of extra houses because
at the end of the day you know most of
us concrete the whole area so that
that's further south of water over
because there is benefit in providing
houses because somebody else will take
them but that's not the way our core
strategy looks it looks at
sustainability and the NPP F is
absolutely clear it is in favor of
sustainable development not never-ending
development and I'm quite happy if the
you know and then another inspector
looks at this because we need to keep on
demonstrating that we as residents in
this district and elected members of
this district are not happy with our
core strategy being overruled repeatedly
when the original inspector made it
quite clear he expects certainty from
the numbers and it is very disappointing
that subsequent inspectors and I'm fully
aware where you're coming from David if
I can call you the first mr. Jeffrey on
this occasion it's very disappointing
that you know inspectors who have not
spent the time and the effort with that
inspector
Giroux spent on our own policy article
strategy decided succeptible drove over
all his very clear words about certainty
with the numbers he could have drawn a
line straight through that station he
chose not to he wanted left
having made some remembrances you know
made remember that stop Papa policy so I
very much support where Council crumble
I'm by the way issue the Chairman you
were referring to this general notch
firm at that point I think yes the maybe
you need for the right but this there is
not a need for these in this particular
location and one I do have one point of
clarification if I may mr. chairman the
SPD's our material planning
considerations are they not yes I can
confirm they are material planning
considerations there I cited in the
officer's report and if you allow me for
a minute to reply to thought you just
said counselor kettle I think you set
out at the beginning of what you said
identifying that the parish council
correctly suggested that there would be
some benefit arising from housing in
this location simply put if members
choose to put a reason for refusal on
this application which outright states
that category to service village which
has exceeded the approximate numbers
should not be considered for new housing
development then that will prevent this
house site coming forward in the future
until such time as a new cost strategy
is adopted on we've lost that 5-year has
advanced apply that is why I think
inspectors have chosen not to do that in
the past they have looked at this as an
approximate finger and they have
considered how an excess against that
proximate figure affects the benefit
that arises from new housing in that
particular location if we are going to
say that there is less benefit than in
other areas of the district by
delivering houses in here because it has
exceeded its allowance then we are
entitled to say that the harm that
arises from poor design should carry the
day in that respect but it says
counselor prompt defined is a come
nation of things rather than two
separate masses all right cancer kettle
you obviously your trips to China have
been rubbing off on you because I never
thought that here device feeding the
Dragon Committee so thank you for that
anymore Chinese proverb so okay texture
has been recommended that we send him
back to China but not just yet five
impacts it sounds to me that that is the
it sounds to me as if we've got them in
that it does refer to pickle impact an
assessment of the visual impact on the
local landscape or townscape and the
sights immediately and wider settings
and this one I go back to what what's
been said it is very cramped and I also
believe strong is the both the
counselors have said the parish and the
local that it doesn't fit in with the
requirements that the village wants and
needs and just to fill in a gap with
houses that are too tightly together
without giving more consultation to the
parish I think is wrong and therefore
underline what I've said before about
refusing so just make sure we're clear
what we're saying is that the benefits
yep okay we'll take a slide to German
and because one cancer is up to leave
the room so if you just bear with me for
two seconds Oh Jimmy gobble and we just
have a break for two seconds and if
anybody else wants to get a drink I
could do a couple again neither
Committee Chairman or auctioneer I could
be right then so just clarifying what I
was saying is that the benefits of this
development in its current form is
considered to be out wide by the
discipline of hits or
yeah I thought you said no that wasn't
it was note so anyway I'll start again
so I think what we've come up with so
far is that the Parish Council realized
this potential for development on this
site would need to fit in with the local
vernacular that local needs met cetera
the current development application in
its current form because of this song is
because street scene poor design etc
added to the potential aggregate and
aggravating factors of the numbers but
we might have to put onto one side
depending on what the offices recommend
I think we're getting to the fact that
we've had a proposal to refuse this
application have we've got a seconder
just careful second but we just came for
those reasons shared the reasons that
I've got this far trying to encapsulate
all that's been said so far in the
meeting is that the the application
would be refused the proposed
development by virtue of its size scale
massing and design would result in harm
to the locality and the street scene the
village has exceeded its approximate
housing allocation and as such in this
case the benefit to be afforded new
housing development is correspondingly
limited as such in this case the
development is found to conflict with
cs9 of the core strategy I'd recommend
that our forms the basis of the wording
which I would seek to agree with the
chairs
all righty comments in cs5 and c60 yeah
we would look to incorporate cs9 as the
principal policy in respective design
and CS 16 in respect of the principal
policy relating to housing them as the
AAS the SPD also be referred to I'm just
gonna say one it's not exceeding number
it's significantly exceeding the number
I think that is important it wouldn't be
a problem
yes I will note and so we've had a
proposal we've had a second to refuse
the application all those in favor are
you happy with so all those in favor of
refusing the application please
unanimous chair so canceled results to
refuse application 19 / 1 5 1 0 it's not
a few out thank you if the facility is
quickly and get some water
next item on the agenda which is thank
you
nineteen slash zero two five seven zero
a few our trial the school of a new self
advised evesham direction added touch
Thank You chair this application is a
full planning application for the
erection of a new detached dwelling the
application site lies in the local
service village of self reprise
identified by the black dots on the plan
the site is located within the
settlement with existing housing
surrounding this is an aerial view of
the application site and its
surroundings with a new dwelling to be
sited in the existing rear garden of
twelve School Avenue this is the
proposed bot block plan with the access
to the site coming off Ridsdale close
and two-car parking space is proposed to
the front of the dwelling and a private
garden to the rear here we have the
plans of the proposed dwelling which
will have two bedrooms the design will
be a simple flat fronted house with
porch canopy to the front I now have a
couple of photos with the site and
surroundings here we stood on Ridsdale
close looking towards the application
site with the proposed dwelling to be
set back from the road this is taken
from within the application site looking
towards the rear of the neighboring
properties at 31 and 32 school Road
standing further down Ridsdale close the
application site is to the right of the
photo with the rear of 12 School Avenue
in the background and the side of 13
School Avenue to the left of the photo
this is a slightly wider feature of the
street scene again with the application
site on the right hand side there are
narrow updates to the application the
application site is considered to lie
within the physical confines at the
village of Salford priors and is not
considered to harm the character of the
area neighboring amenity or highway
safety chair the recommendation is to
grant the application subject to the
conditions set out on page 25 of the
agenda first speaker which is catch the
tarnish oh please good evening catch
this out good evening thank you got
three minutes you want a warning with
about 30 seconds to go
okay thank you far away so you know the
parish council have objected to this
proposal and whilst the idea idea of
infill building is encapsulated in our
NDP any proposed infill should not
affect the safety of road users and
pedestrians nor should it look out of
place with industry seen it should be
noted this area was not identified as a
proposed site within the NDP the post
off isn't a shop but could you would you
mind putting the layout up please the
plan so there is a post office right on
the corner who say local shop as well
thank you and that has recently been
taken over and has seen the Keene
increase in both pedestrian and vehicle
traffic and is also open later than
before until 7:00 p.m. so obviously more
traffic being used there's limited
parking on the shop for court boots
they'll close within then used the party
and that creates a potential safety
hazard within approximately access that
proposed property similarly increased
levels of pedestrians using the access
footpath between bridge now closed and
school up would you mind just
identifying that please so that's right
by that yeah that's a good one as well
and so you can see the pedestrian access
through there to the shop we believe a
danger in relation to the property
access in our opinion the proposed
property will significantly delay the
look at the speed ceiling
close again if you look at that
photograph there it's it's almost in the
middle of two sets of houses about 20
meters either side of there and there's
a if you look at the street scene there
is absolutely nothing there apart from
Gardens so putting a property right in
the middle of that or we absolutely
isolated and will stick out offer you to
use this little bit like a sore thumb in
that location we also know that the
intention is to reduce the height of
fencing to the side of the dwelling
which to us but that's actually
exacerbate that situation of being
isolated note the comparison to the site
at five bridge now close that suggests
that the hedge screening to one side and
houses to the other means it blends
better to the street scene permission
for that build was granted prior to our
NDP sure permission be granted it was
touched on again in the previous
legislation should put the finishing he
wanted the private counsel would draw
attention to the need for the materials
used in construction could be in
accordance to that stipulate in the NDP
so there's nothing's a spare the a
slated nature of the dwelling thank you
thank you cancer cell well within time
any questions for the park as another
property that's being given permission
can you indicate what that is yeah I
think cancer shall refer to that one
didn't you that's in there thank you
I've got two questions consultation
bothered about the Pope of the parish
council was only any discussions with
yourselves
and I've seve cease not identified as an
area and DP which you mentioned you
support they said you support the
principle of in for what appropriate
happier identified any of those areas of
info in the NDP my conflict two areas
one of which is having 14 houses put put
on and that's on the outskirts of the
village on the main road at the bottom
of this picture and also at the bottom
of the picture and there's an infill on
somebody's garden of two properties
being put up there they did apply for
planning permission we objected on the
design of those properties and
subsequently that design has been
changed and we've accepted those
properties to be built and there are
under construction there thank you very
much no the questions counsel careful of
just in time can you put your mic on
please
thank you just looking at the the layout
in thank you you've got where the access
is is currently the access to number is
a number twelve already where does
number twelve currently parked their car
so that is that is currently used for
number 12 okay thank you any questions
this could be awesome kettled pretend
all these whistle taking the question
that you refer to to the last parish
council about the requirements with in
the area for a different type of housing
is that something that the parish we're
looking for there but you might phone on
place I do
we've got just actually to the left of
this picture there's a development going
in there are 84 houses they have got
affordable houses bungalows all mainly
in keeping with the properties that
we're talking about
thank you you're free to go counselor
shell and thank you for answering the
questions they're fully right our next
speaker is mr. Kerry Phillips please
we've got three minutes mr. Phillips and
again where you want to warning we're
about 30 seconds thank you thank you
very much mr. chairman
countless offices this particular site
are we class as a windfall so I'm really
here to respond to the comments
obviously from councillors in regards to
the development so although there wasn't
consultation initially with the parish
council we did take very seriously the
comments in relation to the access to
the site and did have initial
discussions prior to any submission to
the district council with the Highways
Authority and at no point of they raised
any concern with this access that said
we've looked very closely at the site
and what we've actually done we believe
will improve the visibility to that
footpath by removing what is effectively
a six-foot high fence that runs around
the site at the moment lowering that to
a 1200 high palisade fence which will
obviously make that feel like a
pleasanter space and open that part of
the road obviously it's quite a poor
integer that you've got at the moment
and it has been used for store in a
caravan but the park into the property
is actually parking to the properties
actually in school Avenue itself so
there is a written rich down close if
you go onto Google you'll see that the
site has been used for parking the
caravans obviously so there isn't in
theory an issue with access in the site
and by removal of that six foot high
fence we will in fact improve that
access now going back to the scheme
itself originally it was submitted for
a three-bedroom house with no
overlooking to the rear garden area
which is actually screen that the
property adjacent by our buildings to
the rear and at the front of the
property we've made the unit single
aspect and overlooking distance there is
30 metres but as I say the property was
originally designed to be a
three-bedroom home we've now amended it
in accordance with the sulphate Breyers
neighborhood plan which actually is more
restrictive in parking in respect to the
council's Owen SPG design guidance we're
normally two spaces for three-bedroom
house would be satisfactory so this is
actually going to be a two-bedroom house
with two off street parking spaces which
are to the larger county council
standards so in principle we're
providing a very large garden and a
property that follows establish building
lines front and back we'll follow the
vernacular that will match existing
materials so it's a fitting with that
street scene thank you very much the
parking to number 12 of the it shows the
frontage but it doesn't show the pond so
potentially that's a three-bedroom house
that has sufficient parking for two
spaces off road yes yes
could you point out on that previous
goth
but where is the park in the off-road
parking for number 12
sorry it's effectively where we're
circling now so really it's a it's a
mirror of the parking that we're
creating on Ridgedale thank you thank
you you're free to go sir thank you
right move on to the Fleming five
minutes of Fleming and we'll give you
video warning if you okay thank you very
much mr. chairman and the committee for
this opportunity I've encountered
situations like this one in my ward over
the last three years both as a ward
member and as a parish council planning
chair
not for this parish council incidentally
at each of these permissions been
refused and subsequently appeals have
been dismissed I'm here to support the
Salford prosperous Council this
objection to the planning application
the PC and the Parish Council has a made
NDP which was not excluding back garden
development specifically just so the
development should only be in the
current three defined development sites
within sulphate priors which is in
excess of 80 houses the application has
several problems as far as the local
residents concerned there are some
written objections but the parish
council feel that this proposed
development would be detrimental to the
existing street scene exiting the site
would be arrested due to its close
proximity to a the junction with the
main road it's opposite existing
driveway because people have to reverse
out of anyway and it's close to the post
office carpark area where there is
regular vehicle movements since the the
shop recently changed hands it has been
very very busy the main thing for me is
the footpath that comes from school
Avenue alongside number 12 school Avenue
and that terminates where this
exit would be and as it stands and we've
heard some talk about a fence change
it's completely blind to possess dreams
coming up that narrow narrow footpath
and if somebody's pushing a buggy
they're the last person to see what's
backing out of that driveway so if there
was child in a buggy somebody in a
wheelchair they're going to be in the
line of fire before somebody can
actually see it in short mr. chairman I
think this is an inappropriate site for
this development and I would urge the
committee to refuse it and to say on
this stage just making sure thank you to
go it was like are you really sure right
we'll move on to points of clarification
therefore the offices and can you please
ensure life finish that answering the
questions before you start answering
another thank you okay thread sorry I
think it was mentioned earlier but I
can't remember the fence is going to run
along that footpath up to the point of
where the cars are coming on and off how
tall is that going to be please
and so the submitted plans show that
there's going to be a one point 8 meter
high closed boarded fence which will end
approximately here
however if members felt that that was
still too tall and notwithstanding
condition could be used but asked for
further boundary treatment details that
would effectively require a lower fence
to give better visibility tell me I
don't know where the proposed I think
that said there was one point two meters
Paulo side fence what do you propose
that I can't see any palisade fencing
this and the site plan shows
and 1 point 8 meter closed boarded
fencing coming up here across the site
to meet the rear point of I might be
able to come back mr. Phillips can you
just come back to answer that question
please
ok no I might have misheard let me see
under study he could put them mic back
on he mentioned something I'm sure you
did honest I'm going mad
at one point two meter palisade fence
sorry the the intention was that the
front parking area should have a 1.2
meter high palisade and then obviously
once it goes from the say if you follow
the arrow so along here will be a fence
which will meet the outbuilding and then
follow down here and down the rear
garden here so effectively all of this
where I'm showing the arrow will be the
sights of the new house so this area
here will be the rear garden and number
12 School Avenue will retain a rear
garden to to the rear and then also a
triangular space to the side just to
follow that up could the house have been
pushed the building pushed back nearer
to number 12 our buildings or
is that the best yeah I think I think
we've got the applicator we got to put
the application in front yeah we've got
to determine the application in front of
us and the details that have been
submitted as part of this application
officers have considered to be
acceptable mr. Kirkland um two questions
for you I asked about earlier on by the
access for parking for the current
property in isolation number twelve and
that is the proposed entrance in the
bottom left-hand corner and it was
commented that the new parking for
number twelve would be at the top corner
is the access of streets called the
school looks cool thank you miss out is
is the access of school lane onto the
premises or is there is an existing
curve and pavement which is going to
have to be amended to allow the vehicle
to go in there and insufficient parking
in that area to replace the parking that
has been lost by being allocation of
this new house so my understanding from
my site visit is that currently the area
of the application site is mainly being
used for storage of a caravan 12 School
Avenue has parking to the front of the
property you can see here and the row of
houses and they've all got parking along
the frontage and the proposed site will
obviously be severed from the existing
property in that parking will be
exclusively for the proposed dwelling
so effectively number 12 is losing its
off street parking without the corona I
believe number 12 has the parking to the
front at school Avenue but not not on
their own private ground it on on the
highway and it appears that it probably
is on on the driveway but said there is
a drive off school lane onto the
property
do you want so you have a look at Google
Street View confirm that mr. chairman is
this Google Streetview was taken at
night
sorry about that
we appear to have a loose connection to
the network while its while it's loading
as you know on the previous application
I was concerned about the impact on
street scene I think this is a
fundamentally different property but
clearly there's a certain symmetry at
the top end of school lane with this
standing out in the back garden somebody
I think mentioned that there has been a
similar development in the opposite
corner if it were might call a mirror
image does this to sign in any way
replicate the design of that approved
building and I can show you in a minute
at the design if they approved where
they put the other approved house has
gone and the plans for that
apology's chair I think we're not going
to be able to view Google Street View at
this time
I have here a zoomed in image of the
satellite picture that we were looking
at before which shows the arrangement at
school Avenue
in respect to your and second question
and the recently approved dwelling and
is located up here on this site these
are the plans for it so you can see this
is a block plan with it located between
these two your properties it's a
slightly different design dwelling in
the sense that it has a gable fronting
onto the road and it has three bedrooms
and this is a photo of it currently
under construction
am I correct in thinking that was I
think the Chancellor said that it was
approved before the SP and the
application for this site was approved
in 2019 and the neighborhood development
plan was adopted
prior to 2019 the hills thanks for
Jeremy if it would assist if my memory
serves me right from school lane they
there were parking on their on their
Drive it was except perhaps a kettle was
alluding to whether it was off and yes
they are a part they do Park on their
driveway I can see all the numbers it
appears that there's a and school life
anew has a turning circle and then there
is frontages where cars where the car
was that little roundabout on there
although they were parking on the
round-the-world not side and the bottom
left-hand corner it was up where the car
van was being installed
yes that's correct sorry I'm sorry oh
it's small bit of fencing to be put in
on the on the pathway what is reason
that my candy stairs age I mean it's and
so you can you can see I'm here there
currently is fencing sorry just find the
plan and so if you follow the arrow here
and there they're proposing from this
point back along the site at 1.8 me to
close bordered friend and but as stated
earlier a condition could be worded to
achieve different boundary details if
that was loud appropriate I just wonder
why they they you need to do that was
all getting rid of that page okay on
that plan you've got there how saying
the cars are gonna have to back out onto
the street
is there a footpath which would gives
the cars as they back out some sort of
visibility from what I see there you've
got one fence right up against the
roadside and the other one is setback a
smaller amount and if that shop is as
busy as we are led to believe surely it
is going to get quite dangerous people
backing out onto the onto the road and
you can see here that the currents
wooden gates are set back from the
highway and to the left of the photo and
that the fence essentially about to the
highway and that there isn't a footpath
a pavements that
follows along that side of the road we
have consulted with County highways and
they have raised an objection to the
proposal surprised and they're so
difficult about people coming our nose
out that you've got to have that display
and yet when you're reversing out
they're not concerned
I suppose this is depends on each
individual application John
combination different circumstances I
think the common comments of the highway
officer have been concluded having
regard to the type of nature of the
street and the apparent Arrangements the
general disposition of the area is I
think it's also relevant to note that
it's in existing access people be using
that access in its current form is that
one that has been taken on by
prospective rights or is it something
that the owner of the land has just
taken into and just put the gates there
to movies caravan unter and that's not
clear from the planning history of the
site you're right in saying that there
isn't an existing drop curb at the
moment and I can't confirm that there is
a formalized access there at the moment
sorry just quickly my own understanding
there's a made NDP there's a couple of
sites allocated already for infill but
the one that's up the road a little bit
it was done after the NDP was made
that's what you said earlier so okay
that's what I need it's not exactly if
you can go back to that aerial view keep
going the aerial view yeah this one
we're looking at has taken a corner of
that triangle out and the triangle in
the garden on the other side has not
been affected and that appears to be a
square bit of land so it's sort of more
in line with infill the one we're
looking at tonight
is that correct and yes you're correct
in and saying that one further at the
road it's a more square plot of land but
that there isn't necessarily a
definition of infield that requires that
the size or shape of land to be info you
can go after judge the application on
its own merit okay sometimes you can
compare for some of the ones but again
it's unique to its application so we
just have to judge it on its merits on
this application off have you got a plan
of the previous one
parking and say this is the plan both
the slight further at the road so you
can see here there are two new car
parking
so this is the parking so things would
be going elsewhere so they would there
isn't a turning facility it's yeah
showing three car parking spaces looks a
better situation okay thank you at the
end of the cul-de-sac all the clothes
there's lines down there or is that just
another entrance to another property and
if I go back to the aerial view of the
site sorry bear with me so this is the
site that's been approved last year you
can see that close to it there's an
access to another closed and then this
further housing that carries on down the
road so yes not quarter no right then
should we we want to debate on this one
caster Thank You chairman I've listened
to what everybody said it is different
to the existing properties in the area
but it isn't fundamentally different in
the way those other properties were had
it been by itself I could have persuaded
myself that it was going to to use the
parish council comments account like a
sore thumb but there is a in a way
although not an exact symmetry there was
a similar trajectory one the one that we
have talked about a lot which is not
sucked at supplication but I'm just
purely talking about the impact on the
street scene we can't compare one
property against the other in terms of
plenty application but just as it stands
there will be two properties facing on
to the road at least as opposed to
this the parking issue I have managed to
bring up Google others do Google Maps
and it does appear there's a large
tarmac area in front of number 12 from
the map and I've been able to see here
and it was just in the neighborhood sort
of parking going on there so I think my
concerns about parking probably have
dissolved so if I was going to object
and mr. Jeffries will persuade me
otherwise it would be again on housing
numbers I mean although the sulfur
development never development plan is
looking at 134 houses and the allocation
of such as and another speed to it's
only 84 of which they're already at
about 100 and where are they 142 I think
of being built in the area I'm I'm not
going to rehearse the arguments of what
I said the mr. Jeffries pointed out it's
not very sustainable so if there were
significant other issues I would use
that to prop up an argument that this is
not a good place for development it is
only one property it's not like three
squeezed onto plot I have find no
planning reasons to refuses application
I know that we'll be responding to Ward
number in the parish council it was it's
difficult to look at a genuine reason
where we could stand up and say this is
wrong if it is not the sore thumb that
we saw earlier on although clearly it is
different in the parish council does not
share my way
because the most thanks for show
stretching our thumb I hope it will use
that expression if I do think it stands
out like sore thumb
it's some when I went there looked in
through the guard or Crompton's being
squeezed in but I have to say I was
quite surprised as the amount of garden
it has but can I think of a good
planning reason to turn it down
but I still think it's down south a
sight like a sore thumb but can we use
that probably not thank you mr. fielding
looking at verse five Cs five let the
landscape and the immediate wider second
and nine where you're looking at the
stink givenness a sensitive proposal
including layers and orientation I can't
look as a sensitive design I don't like
the idea of backing out and I and I had
a feeling at one time we were very
concerned about tandem parking where
people were backing out into the street
and we were making we were refusing or
making very strong disapproval and here
we've got roughly the same except
they're not one behind the other I don't
think there's enough visibility to back
a car out with a boot I don't think
there's it's not even in a sort of a
street scene alignment with the other
buildings further up I'm of the opinion
that it's over too much for the site and
therefore table development and I will
go for refusal again
doesn't think that I'm sure the planning
obviously looked at that does it's it
beyond the bill what they call the
building line you know it's no my
concern about what I can understand your
concerns about backing out and we have
to be careful that we judge everything
on its own merit including speed lb
speeds of the vehicles they're not Road
my only concern my concern about that is
that the Highways Authority has done
their assessment and they've not so do
you think about that and I know we can't
go against the hallways Authority's
recommendations but I think we're on
dangerous ground if you use that as one
of the there yet reasons to refuse if
you were considered considering that so
I would be very wary if you wanted to
use that reason
well those four reason for a refusal
going against what highways have said
what I'm basically saying is that we can
state that highways may have not have
taken into account the fact there's a
new shop there which is getting a lot
more traffic and unlike everything else
with a new shop people speak I think I
think I'll come to you in a second I
think we could be very careful if maybe
inputs is some of the words there we've
got to have the evidence in front of us
which says we don't think the council
has taken to account x y&z but at the
moment I'm not seeing that and I'm very
concerned about that
and for been told it's not a new shop as
well it's not a new shop but the it's
been trading for a while so so again we
do have to be careful careful
highways response was stated the
beginning of January and that was
following a recommendation in December
and they previously had no objection on
the 18th of November so they've
obviously been asked to go back and look
at it at some stage by for some reason I
would absolutely support the chairman
and saying we can't make any assumptions
about ifs and buts we have no objection
from the highways we can't say did they
would they don't consider it they are
ultimately paid as the professionals on
this and I think to second-guess what
they might or might not have done it's a
very dangerous position I don't always
agree with highways particularly mr.
Nash's grinning at that point emeritus
counsel but but that is where there's
our highways officer who we've been able
to challenge and to take to task from
the beauties put forward or her we can't
do that here we have to accept that
highways have said they have no
objection they've done it twice
having relooked of it a second time at
the beginning of this beginning this
year which is awful as we know only 30
days ago so I'm really not comfortable
with any highways objection I think we
could be shot down in flames on that
basis transitory and I'm going back to
what I was saying about zs9 sensitivity
distinctiveness and cs5 basically the
street scene I've I can't see this
design as being compatible with what we
like to have in the district that I I
will sit back and
my peers make their comments open
listening to all the debate I'm
struggling as well to find a good enough
reason to refuse the application myself
I was considering the NDP line but I
think that in terms of limiting in
filter one property that precedent has
been set since that NDP has been made so
I'm not sure there's really anywhere
that won't come back to haunt us if we
work to try and refuse this myself so on
that basis I think I'd like to propose
that we grant as per the officers
recommendations but also I would like
that condition about the low fence next
to the footpath to give the better
visibility to the pedestrians and
presumably actually possibly the people
backing onto or off the drive proposal
to refuse them proposal to run what we
have two conflicting proposals but
cancer
fielding codeine is proposal first
hopefully a seconder for catch the
buildings approval and refusal no cancer
I didn't then it has Authority's
proposal to agree to grant the
application our yes seconder for that
put him in defending and yeah Casa
kettle so you're a second and with the
amended with the amended
so we've had a proposal on the second
day to grab the application all those in
favor
we laptop Li mr. chairman against one
jamming abstentions committee resolves
to grant application 19 / 0 2 5 7 0 / if
you are thank you we have no items of
urgent business
so I'll declare the meeting closed thank
you